[Musica]
esistono realmente quei momenti in cui
possiamo decidere di cambiare la nostra
vita che possiamo decidere di spezzare
le abitudini la zona di comfort esistono
né voglio farvi vedere una foto vedete
queste due persone queste due persone
sono in realtà la stessa a due anni di
distanza nei più grandi differenze non
sono la barba ei capelli
no è la cravatta quel nodo che mi facevo
tutte le mattine prima di andare a
lavorare in banca
quel nodo era per osmosi un nodo in gola
una lingua dettato dal malessere perché
io stavo vivendo una vita che no non mi
apparteneva realmente stavo vivendo
secondo le aspettative di quelli che mi
stavano intorno della società degli
amici però aveva una grandissima
passione dentro di me che ho scoperto un
po più tardi ovvero il viaggio ma non il
viaggio così inteso come vacanza no
l'incontro tra le culture le tradizioni
l'andare incontro anche al diverso e
vivevo una vita fatta di 11 mesi l'anno
di lavoro di malessere per ritagliarmi
un mese di vita un giorno ero in treno
stavo rientrando dal lavoro e fuori
c'era il classico autunno della pianura
padana nuvoloni neri io stavo come tanti
guardando lo smartphone scorrendo le
notizie di facebook e sarà capitato
certamente anche a voi di trovarvi
massime post aforismi di cantanti
scrittori poeti ma anche di persone
comuni che vi dicono come la vita sia
una sola che vada vissuta pienamente che
bisogna inseguire i sogni andarseli a
prendere è facile a dirsi po più
difficile a farsi forse quel giorno
anziché schiacciare laico condividi fu
in qualche modo svegliato da quello che
accadeva fuori dal finestrino per
khedira dal finestrino questi nuvoloni
neri avevano lasciato spazio a un
tramonto meraviglioso un sole caldo che
mi ha fatto breccia nell'anima nel cuore
perché non ne potevo più di vivere tutti
i giorni nell'acciaio di quel vagone che
mi portava il lavoro non è
ritoccare cemento ne potevo più di
calpestare asfalti avevo bisogno di
natura sentivo richiamo fortissimo
quel giorno quando tornai a casa gli
amici davanti allo specchio per farmi
una semplice domanda
date le premesse immagino che abbiate
già compreso quale fosse la risposta ma
forse il caso di fare un passo indietro
interrogarci su che cos'è la felicità
andiamo per semplicità cerchiamo su
google felicità questa è la definizione
che esce da wikipedia
quindi proprio la più bassa non stiamo a
girarci tanto intorno
la felicità è lo stato d'animo o
emozione positivo di chi ritiene
esauditi tutti i propri desideri
ora sono in grado di risponde alla
domanda sono felice no potrei mai essere
felice un giorno no perché non stavo
vivendo i miei desideri non sto vivendo
i miei sogni non stavo vivendo secondo
il mio fuoco interiore e allora ho detto
per essere felici
forse bisogna andare alla ricerca del
grande sogno nel cassetto provare a
realizzarlo
il problema era che il mio grande sogno
nel cassetto da fare il giro del mondo
cicero del mondo a voi avete idea di
quanto possa costare il giro del mondo
eccolo il primo dito dietro cui ci
nascondiamo le scuse che accampiamo
vedete a me non è mai interessato
viaggiare per resort business class
hotel a 5 stelle non c'è niente di male
tutto questo ci mancherebbe ma non è
quello che andavo cercando io andavo
cercando quelli situazioni l'ente
scomode come quei bus del guatemala
piuttosto che dell'india o del nepal
dove per fare un tragitto di un'ora
un'ora e mezza ce ne vogliono 8 e quei
viaggi solo con gli ammortizzatori
scarichi e passi tutto il tempo ed è
sotto le tue gambe c'è una capra sopra
le tue ginocchio da galline da parte una
signora nel paese che ti guarda così
all'inizio diffidenza quella di firenze
incomincia a diventare curiosità perché
il mal di schiena che sentivo io lo
sentiva anche quella signora perché il
mio disagio dall'avere tutte queste
persone una sopra l'altra
quel disagio ce l'avevo io ma c'erano
anche le persone intorno a me
piano piano diventavo uno di loro le
persone ti aprono il cuore ti aprono al
loro mondo davvero proprio perché sei
parte di loro quindi la curiosità
diventa accoglienza ti invitano bere un
tè e ti invitano a mangiare ti apro le
porte di caso ti aprono anche solo lo
scorso su un paesaggio che nessuna guida
al mondo e nessun forum di viaggiatore
online potrà mai a regalarvi beh ma
allora non mi servono tutti si sodio
messere vince alla lotteria per fare il
giro del mondo
incomincia a ragionarci seriamente il
dito piano piano si sposta incomincia a
pensare che potrei fare un giro del
mondo in mille giorni spendendo 15 euro
al giorno
bene ok si può fare
però manca un passaggio avrei dovuto
licenziarmi investirà liquidazione
vendere la mia auto e comunque non sarei
arrivato alla cifra necessaria per oro
convinto sono un inguaribile ottimista
letto ce la si può fare
il problema grosso a licenziarsi in un
momento di crisi come questo
io lavoravo in banca
era un quadro direttivo vice direttore
di filiale di una banca importante però
vedete quest'immagine un uccellino una
gabbia volti di sicurezza non sono le
stesse per le persone non hanno lo
stesso risultato
nocerino una gabbia tutto se ci pensate
a chi dà da mangiare a una vaschetta con
l'acqua fresca
i più fortunati hanno anche un osso di
seppia da beccare io ero proprio i quali
fortunati larga 32 anni avevo tutto però
quella gabbia quelle sicurezze minavano
la mia fragilità di un incertezza ed ero
tremendamente innamorata di me
incertezze ed è proprio come l'uccellino
che se gli ha anche sa tutto gli aprì la
porticella gabbia si libera verso il
cielo verso il mondo
io sentivo le stesse identiche cose
questo perché la sua natura è quella
anche se a tutto benissimo però il dito
si sposta sempre di più ma non vi ho
raccontato una cosa dall'età di 9 anni
soffrono di diabete è una patologia che
a tratti poi sono anche invalidante
sicuramente una malattia complessa molto
molto personale e io mi sono confrontato
ovviamente con il medico adesso sono
tecnologie che aiuta
non ci sono sensori che voglio dirle
mandano il profilo glicemico
direttamente via mail ci sono le
tecnologie tipo o semplicemente come
whatsapp e poi fotografare un cibo e
chiedere un parere però mi sono accorto
che non tutta la comunità diabetica la
pensava come me e non eran siato da un
viaggio del genere grazie soprattutto
probabilmente ai miei genitori che non
hanno trasmesso la loro ansia la mia
allora che ho iniziato a credere che
questa storia
questa testimonianza poteva appunto
dimostrare alla qualità devi dire che si
poteva fare che ci poteva essere un
futuro più subito per i figli di
genitori diabetici e allora mi son detto
va bene
a questo punto si può fare suite therapy
la terapia del viaggio ma col diabete
piuttosto semplice momento in cui si
gestisce la scorta di medicinali anche
se questo vuol dire magari fare una buca
nella sabbia nel deserto del sahara per
tenerla all'ombra a durante la giornata
quando non c'è niente in più ero
abituato a passare 8 10 davanti alla
scrivania fare venti venticinque
chilometri al giorno di cammino
l'avrebbe sicuramente risolto però era
anche una testimonianza verso chi voleva
cambiare vita verso quel me stesso prima
quando ero in banca io volevo
semplicemente dimostrare questo che il
cambiamento è dentro di noi non nel
mondo fuori di cui ci lamentiamo trip
therapy la terapia del viaggio ma può
essere anche un balsamo per l'anima
perché vedete in viaggio non è che
succede chissà cosa succede anche nella
vita normale
le risposte le troviamo tutti i giorni
il problema restano le domande a domanda
sbagliata seguirà una risposta sbagliata
e ovvio che in viaggio e un inizio una
fine hai un collegamento tra l'episodi
quelle che io chiamo anche le correnti
universali agli orecchi più tese agli
occhi più attenti
forse semplicemente in viaggio ti poni
più domande di quando stai a casa
vedete io sono partito da una domanda
sei felice sono tornato da tre mesi
vi posso dire che la felicità l'ho
toccata con mano
tante volte ed è lì agguanta bill è
afferrabile a portata di mano se
seguiamo i nostri sogni se seguiamo le
nostre passioni
oggi ho in mano la mia vita oggi lo
secondo le mie aspettative non quelle
degli altri è fatto un blog di successo
ho iniziato a fare video per la
televisione e che non vorrò televisione
da 78 anni o autoprodotto un libro senza
casa editrice che ha venduto più di 4000
copie in tre mesi
e tutto questo perché cito le parole di
mio padre quel giorno ho preso una
decisione lucidamente folle perché ho
seguito i miei sogni
ora vi chiedo gentilmente di venire un
minuto nello zaino con me in giro per il
mondo
[Musica]
no
[Applauso]
[Musica]
allora è questo che vi dico messaggio
che voglio lasciarvi fate lo fate anche
voi non il giro del mondo quello no
provate interrogarvi davvero mettervi
davanti allo speck e sinceramente ad
ascoltare il vostro bambino interiore
quello che è il vostro cuore
quello che vi anima quello per cui vale
la pena vivere non posticipati oggi
adesso grazie
[Applauso]